[Musica]
sono un inguaribile sognatore
ho cominciato a sognare quando avevo 14
15 anni ero uno studente liceale andavo
naturalmente bene a scuola ha
predisposto per le materie scientifiche
e ottenevo degli ottimi risultati
studiando molto poco è finito di
studiare mi annoiavo terribilmente
mentre aspettavo che mi ami cio la mia
fidanzatina finissero di studiare anche
loro cercavo continuamente all'interno
delle enciclopedie all'interno di tutto
quello dei libri che trovavo in casa
stimoli per volare con la fantasia per
trovare nuovi stimoli e soddisfare il
mio desiderio di apprendere di scoprire
il mondo non c'era ancora internet la
televisione iniziava alle 5 un quarto e
cercavo continuamente questi stimoli che
sognavo sognavo anche l'amore romantico
di di dante e di beatrice sognavo di
diventare una rockstar e di avere una
vita spericolata erano gli anni in cui
vasco rossi cantava quella canzone nella
mia cameretta
sognavo di diventarlo anch'io dopo una
furiosa lite condominiale ho dovuto
rimandare ho dovuto rimandare il mio
sogno ma mi hanno detto che ho ancora
qualche speranza
e allora ho cercato qualcos'altro per
poter esprimere la mia creatività
insieme a mio fratello che un po più
grande di me con i primi risparmi dei
lavoretti fate d'estate abbiamo
comperato il nostro primo personal
computer abbiamo comperato il comodo 64
e abbiamo scoperto una passione la
possibilità di esprimersi creando il
software che poi ci ha accompagnato e ci
accompagna per tutta la nostra vita
professionale e sognavamo nella nostra
cameretta di cambiare il mondo con le
tecnologie
erano gli anni in cui steve jobs bill
gates jeff bezos nel loro garage in
america creavano le loro grandi
corporation e noi nella nostra cameretta
ma a monza dove viviamo il garage non
sono l'ambiente più piacevole per
creare soft soprattutto d'inverno
sognavamo anche noi di avere il nostro
momento di gloria 20 anni avevamo 1 st
di software e quindi eravamo delle
piccole star
abbiamo creato software per tantissime
aziende che hanno diffuso i nostri
prodotti in tanti contesti ma forse ci
mancava qualche competenza pur essendo
stati molto bravi a scuola
essendoci laureati a pieni voti al
politecnico di milano
ci mancava qualche competenza di
business qualche competenza relazionale
qualche competenza di team building e
allora il mondo ha conquistato noi a 30
anni con una dolorosa separazione ho
cambiato strada è però non ho smesso di
sognare
utilizzando le tecnologie le strategie
creative lavorando con le persone ho
sognato di cambiare le aziende le
organizzazioni sono diventato direttore
generale ho trovato imprenditori che
hanno apprezzato la mia passione la mia
dedizione mi hanno dato aziende da
gestire e faccio questo lavoro ormai da
25 anni
tredici anni fa ho cambiato lavoro con
una nuova famiglia con mia figlia
margherita che iniziava il suo percorso
scolastico ho scelto di entrare in
un'azienda che lavorano il mondo
dell'education dove lavora ancora in un
gruppo che ha varie attività nel mondo
delle due show sognavo di accompagnare
mia figlia nel suo percorso scolastico
questa è una foto della sua cameretta in
cui sognava probabilmente anche lei di
diventare una rockstar però con la
fisarmonica quindi un po diverso mi
piace citare qui a reggio una frase di
loris malaguzzi bambini hanno i cento
linguaggi della creatività dentro di
loro e hanno la capacità il potenziale
il desiderio e la curiosità di costruire
da soli il proprio apprendimento
attraverso delle esperienze e gli adulti
devono soltanto fornire loro le attività
e il contesto nel quale esprime
ho avuto fortuna abbiamo cambiato un po
il modo il mondo della scuola e oggi piu
di 1.400.000 persone utilizzano una app
un sito che ho creato insieme ai miei
collaboratori
nell'azienda che dirigo e siamo un po
entrati nella vita di tanti studenti di
tanti genitori di tanti docenti ma non
ho ancora realizzato il mio sogno
questa nella cameretta la cameretta a
led motivi della mia vita e l'avete
capito e la cameretta di mia figlia mia
figlia non mi ha concesso l'utilizzo
della sua immagine ma vi garantisco che
quando studia sorride un po meno di
quando sognava di diventare una rockstar
e vedete che c'è un libro probabilmente
dello stesso editore dello stesso autore
sul quale studiavo io 40 anni fa c'è il
quaderno probabilmente della stessa
marca max non si può non citare se
l'ipad dove consultare l'enciclopedia
probabilmente di chi pedia che nulla è
rispetto a quella che usavo anch'io
io lo usavo di carta lella usa su un
ipad e magari lo usa anche per guardare
netflix così si distrae un po e poi c'è
lo smart phone lo smartphone con cui
chatta con le amichette magari col
fidanzatino si scambiano magari qualche
versione di latino o qualche compito di
matematica ma di sicuro non riescono a
vivere quell'esperienza sociale
cooperativa che le tecnologie potrebbero
offrire e fuori però dallo studio mia
figlia diversa vive in un contesto che è
totalmente diverso rispetto a quale al
contesto nel quale vivevo io è sovrasti
molara divenne il mondo dei social
network riceve continuamente stimoli
multimediali video immagini
in me me è e continua a essere
sovrastimolazione più abituata ad andare
a cercare come cercavo io i contenuti
nella rete non è più in grado di
scoprire sono abituati oggi giovani a
ricevere continui stimoli insieme al
gruppo di lavoro che condivide con me un
po di questi pensieri i ribelli sul
cambiamento della scuola pensiamo che
debba venire la stessa cosa nella
didattica e che quindi contenuti debbano
arrivare in forma liquida multimediale e
multisensoriale e ragazzi attraverso dei
flussi digitali che devono essere però
non mediati tanto dai loro social
network del piacere ma da qualche cosa
che è collegato alla loro vita
scolastica che è collegata al loro
diario scolastico che è collegato al
loro registro elettronico e che quindi
sia totalmente contestuale rispetto
all'esperienza che fanno la scuola che
fanno a scuola e che sia direttamente
correlata alle valutazioni alle
valutazioni per competenza ai bisogni
educativi speciali che questi ragazzi
hanno in modo totalmente personalizzato
ma da dove possono arrivare tutti questi
stimoli
secondo noi questi stimoli possono
arrivare da una grande biblioteca
didattica innovativa
il nome non è molto originale ma
sicuramente qualche marchettaro riuscirà
a darci qualche suggerimento
intelligente gli ingegneri non hanno
molta fantasia questa biblioteca deve
essere plurilingue multimediale e
multisensoriale tutte le biblioteche
della storia partendo da quella di
alessandra d'egitto si basano su un
unico media e su un'unica tipologia di
contenuto la carta il libro più
recentemente youtube
tutti i video del mondo spotify tutta la
musica del mondo
ted tutte le migliori idee del mondo
khan academy le videolezioni banche dati
di immagini sempre un unico solo
elemento
noi siamo convinti che per fare
didattica ci voglia un aggregazione
ragionare
da coordinata e organizzata di materiali
di natura profondamente diversa che
possano essere aggregati in modo
innovativo che possano essere di lingue
diverse perché magari un ragazzino
straniero può prima a cominciare da un
contenuto nella sua lingua originale e
poi sviluppare contenuti dello stesso
argomento nella lingua di adozione
capendo così anche la terminologia
stessa cosa per uno studente italiano
che poco si attenda delle lingue e
colmare uno dei più grossi divari che
noi abbiamo e siamo convinti che questa
grande libreria digitale possa essere
utilizzata in modo totalmente
personalizzato dai ragazzi secondo le
proprie le proprie attitudini perché
siamo convinti che lo studio debba
essere un viaggio debba essere
un'esperienza in cui il ragazzo è
protagonista e quindi ci immaginiamo che
questa nuovi mattoni della conoscenza
possano essere delle guide di viaggio
virtuali all'interno del quale ogni
ragazzo può trovare il proprio percorso
totalmente personalizzato che potrebbe
essere il partire da un tè del partire
da un podcast all partire da un brano
uno spezzone di un film e poi costruire
il proprio percorso all'interno della
materia e della disciplina scolastica e
siamo convinti che poi debba essere il
protagonista di questo viaggio e che
quindi debba produrre lui il materiale
le foto di viaggio il diario il blog e
lo possa fare questo viaggio
condividendolo con i propri compagni
condividendolo con la classe guidati
magari da un docente o perché no da un
genitore che segue un ragazzino che può
averlo particolare i talenti o bisogni
educativi speciali e mi piace citare
sempre quella ragazzina filippina che a
18 anni ad uscita sintetizzare in due
minuti e mezzo
una delle teorie più complesse e
affascinanti mai concepite dalla mente
umana
la teoria della relatività generale ed è
riuscita a spiegarla senza nessuna
terminologia tech
con un video e se questo potesse
appassionare i ragazzi allo studio della
fisica della matematica che risulta così
ostica allora avremmo fatto
probabilmente qualcosa di innovativo
tutte le biblioteche sono caratterizzate
da un sistema di catalogazione e noi
immaginiamo il sistema di catalogazione
totalmente innovativo che sia
organizzato per tipologia di scuola
dalla scuola dell'infanzia alla scuola
superiore per disciplina scolastica o
extra scolastica e poi che possa essere
organizzata per argomento e per chi
forse fino a qui nulla di diverso ma
soprattutto possa essere organizzato per
competenze perché attraverso il viaggio
il progetto l'esperienza si maturano
delle competenze che possono essere
disciplinari tecniche ma anche quelle
soft skill che oggi sono richieste
saranno sempre più richieste per
affrontare il futuro e per trovare le
informazioni google è sufficiente ma
provate a cercare su google come si fa
esprimere un concetto in tre minuti
come si fa a comunicare in una lingua
differente dei concetti tecnici che sto
studiando non troverete nulla e allora
se riusciamo a fare questo avremo fatto
qualcosa di molto innovativo questa
banca dati deve essere accessibile
ovunque deve partire dall'esperienza
magari della cameretta deve aggregare le
proprie amici e la propria classe ma poi
debba essere anche disponibile a scuola
magari sulla lim dove un docente può
trovare degli stimoli per fare una
lezione diversa e trovare anche una
metodologia e trovare una comunità con
la quale scambiare delle esperienze
sull'efficacia dell'utilizzo di questa
unità didattica e poi possa essere possa
portare fuori anche nel real e che
quindi quell'esperienza che parte dal
digitale possa portare il ragazzo in una
biblioteca per guardarsi un film in una
saletta del cinema insieme ad altri
persone appassionate oppure a sentire la
musica oppure in una saletta con la
realtà virtuale per comprende i viaggi
che magari non ha la fortuna di compiere
e poi possa portarlo fuori anche
all'aperto dove con la realtà aumentata
possa interagire con i due
con i monumenti con la natura per
documentare per creare dei propri
contenuti
e allora l'esperienza parte nel digitale
ma porta nel reale parte da
un'esperienza magari solitaria e porta
all'aggregazione e realizzabile questa
biblioteca
penso di sì faccio il manager non c'è un
amministratore delegato e mi hanno
insegnato che i sogni si chiamano
visioni e che i sogni si possono
realizzare tutte le biblioteche della
storia sono state create con il
contributo dei mecenati dei grandi
mecenati che hanno messo a disposizione
dei fondi per creare queste cose noi
siamo convinti che i grandi mecenati
siano le banche quindi immaginiamoci le
banche le fondazioni i grossi produttori
di contenuti che possono mettere a
disposizione dei contenuti e pensiamo
anche alle scuole ai ragazzi e ai
docenti agli esperti ai genitori che
hanno particolari competenze ed
esperienze che possono contribuire a
organizzare le materie i viaggi nelle
materie nei quali sono esperti e se
riuscissimo a fare questa cosa qui in
italia partendo da reggio emilia la
patria di loris malaguzzi partendo
dall'emilia romagna partendo dell'italia
forse riusciremo anche a realizzare uno
dei sogni che uno dei più grandi
visionari di questi tempi steve jobs
aveva e ne non è riuscito a realizzare
nella sua vita cambiare il modo di
apprendere dei ragazzi e di studiare e
se riuscissimo a farlo in italia a
renderlo disponibile in un sistema
sociale anche a tutte le persone che non
hanno la fortuna di frequentare scuole
private oppure particolarmente
innovative allora avranno fatto anche
qualcosa di socialmente utile
mi piacerebbe che potessimo partire da
qui per costruire questa cosa e vi
lascio con una frase il futuro
appartiene a tutti coloro giovani e meno
giovani ragazzi è più adulti che hanno
il coraggio di credere alla bellezza dei
propri sogni
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]